[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
39th
live stream q and a where we fulfill
your desire to see more pets and answer
your questions
including one super chat question uh for
more cat butt
so we have primed the pump and
put uh cat but appreciating
uh no attracting stuff in the sink
behind us and there we have fairfax's
rear end
you put something in the sink yes okay
that would explain it yes
yes once he's done with what's in the
sink you will presumably be showing his
face to us
aha yes all right we are going to start
with
questions from three questions from
episode 38
and then uh pull a question that came
off of the discord
that was voted on by discord and then uh
walk right into questions from today so
uh number one from last time
given that having gay people in society
seems to be adaptive how did the
homophobia and the abrahamic religions
manage to survive
wow i'm gonna have to um
i'm going to tantalize you with a piece
of an answer without delivering the full
answer because as i keep
saying there's a but before you do that
let me just say
it's having gay people in a society
isn't adaptive that's too universal to
claim right it's going to be adaptive in
particular situations
yeah what i would say is homosexuality
is going to turn out to be adaptive
which doesn't mean it's adaptive in
every case
but i would just say
that i believe the answer to your
question is that the homophobia
is also adaptive and i'm not defending
it but what i'm saying
is that the fact of homosexuality
and the fact of resistance to
it being a phenomenon out in the open
is part and parcel of the same
explanation which i hope to deliver
soon maybe we will get a vaccine we will
be able to return to the world we can
rent a hall
we can wouldn't that be nice being able
to travel again
for instance we'd love to do that yeah
yep it would be terrific all right
sorry i i hate to i hate to put off an
answer here but
it just seems like um bearing it in a q
a is not the way to do it this is
important enough and enough rests on the
way the answer
um functions that i think we have to do
it in
in a larger form the only real driving
factor for men appears to be to have sex
that is until they have children then
the main drive for most shifts to
equipping and protecting their offspring
do you agree that these are the only two
drives for men could they eventually
negate
each other wow yeah i think
uh that's another big one there's a lot
in that question that i would
disagree with right i would say
sex is a major driving factor for men
but that there's really
two versions of that there's the
find a life partner version and the have
sex without commitment version and those
function very differently
the former is closely aligned
with the commitment that men
have to their children when their
certainty of paternity is high
but i wouldn't say that these are the
only drives either in fact i would say
that one of the things that is deranging
society is that
men used to be driven to
achieve things because it allowed them
to partner
with more desirable mates and that that
actually
created a lot of the value in the world
and that
as much as i think
women being freed to participate in
society in all kinds of different roles
is a very positive thing
that it did have this negative
externality which is that
um males are not as motivated to move
mountains as they once were
and so anyway it would be interesting to
have an adult conversation about
how to restore the positives without
banishing anyone to
unfulfilling work
or work they did not prefer and surely
there's a solution to that
but it does involve us being candid and
not pretending uh
that everything is categorical good bad
discrimination liberty that's right um
and you know we explore
we explore this in the book that we are
writing will be out next year and i
explore this in an essay
on the evolution of sex and love uh that
should be out
any day now uh that we will perhaps talk
about just a little bit once
it is out so you'll get you'll get more
on this
soon in this space watch the space final
question from episode 38 that we are
going back to
in your a b political trough model brett
could the a
and b peaks increase or decrease
contralaterally
during societal well-being contraction
and expansion
love you both i'm not sure i'm not sure
exactly what
uh contralaterally means but
you know i i take that to be sort of if
they're on if they're in a line with one
another so
um you know as one increases the other
one decreases could they
increase or decrease contralaterally
during societal
well-being contraction expansion meaning
that you are more likely to drop over
one than the other yeah yeah i see
no reason to expect that they are um
equally uh tall peaks
at any moment they may pass through it
but
yeah would they oscillate um
i'm not sure actually i'm not sure what
increased decrease contralaterally might
mean but i sort of read it as you know
oscillate in some sort of inverse
um correlated matter um manner
and i'm not i don't know i mean you you
cleverly didn't define
a and b you know this will work there's
a model that would work for a number of
different situations across a number of
different moments in time
so well i kind of did i at least
did a prototype version which involves a
uh
a marxist failure mode and a fascist
failure mode
that's right you did um and so i would
say
yeah the danger of those um is not
inherently equal it may equalize over
time because
basically it's a question of which
excesses are you more
deaf to at the moment you're more likely
to go over the peak
that you can't see than the one that you
see because
recent history has informed you about it
at any one moment clearly there is going
to be a greater risk of one than the
other although
one thing that is interesting about this
moment is how
uh is how loudly uh some
on the fringe left are yelling about the
possibility of one outcome
when many of us actually find the other
outcome much more likely
yeah so i would say this is i think a
case where you don't want to over
instantiate the model the model works as
a loose metaphor and it tells you
sort of roughly what the dangers are but
if you try to map it onto the world and
be precise about the height of the peaks
and things
you are liable to lose the value of it
and turn it into something
that will inherently be false because
the map will be imprecise
all right this uh question from
the voters on discord um
let's see i got one of them that i'm
going to hold off for for next time
for reasons that i talked to the guy who
sent it to me about so
we are left with what might explain the
success of the sabbath day of rest
strategy used by religions
perhaps it's a hedge against the harms
of transitioning from hunter-gatherer
lifestyles to
agricultural lifestyles or is there a
deeper reason and do any other animals
take
sabbath um i think i deployed an
answer in one of my very early videos
that right after the evergreen thing
happened
we did talk about so the model i've had
for sabbath for a long time is
that it is a an instantiation of
a um it is an
adaptive state that risks a game
theoretic failure and sabbath is the way
to resist the game theoretic failure and
so the way it works is this
let's say that it is better for society
for everybody to take off at least one
day
a week that working seven days a week it
causes you
to distance yourself from your family
and it
results in all sorts of externalized
harms that aren't good for anybody
so there needs to be a rule that says
take a day off a week but
if you take a day off a week then you're
in a puzzle let's say that you're a
shopkeeper
and what you want to do is you want to
figure out the day of the week that
everybody else
is taking off and the shop is closed and
then you open your shop up and you clean
up because people who are looking to
shop on that day come to your shop
and so what that does is it puts
everybody in motion trying to figure out
whether or not a given day is the right
one to take off in order to take
advantage of the fact that everybody
else
is not doing the job on that day
so this causes another problem
which is it may be that if people are
playing that game trying to find the day
on which their shop will do best
that actually you will cheat and what
you will do is you will
not close your shop because actually you
want to clean up from the days that
everybody is
it's an end run around it's it's a it's
a formalized prescription to avoid the
tragedy of the commons
exactly and so you might say well
um god says take a day off
every week and you can't and this is the
day and this is the day and the thing is
what that allows
to happen is that people can enforce
god's will
because if you open your shop on the
sabbath then you're being sacrilegious
and people will shun you
so that they are not co-stigmatized for
shopping on a day that you're not
supposed to be selling them stuff
so anyway that's the basic point is game
theory explains a formulation in which
god picks a day
and everybody adheres to it and anybody
who doesn't adhere to it is obviously in
violation
that's the way to frustrate the race to
the bottom that otherwise unfolds
yeah and with regard to any other
animals taking sabbath we don't know of
any other animals that manage to avoid
tragedy of the commons race to the
bottom etc
so uh so you know without any external
metaphorical enforcement like uh god
will frown on this behavior
i know i know of no such thing that said
there are regular intervals of rest but
they tend to be imposed by
abiotic forces external abiotic forces
like winter
yeah um i'm wondering if there's not
some example somewhere because
in eleanor ostrom's work she
demonstrates how culture after culture
avoids
game theoretic failures through
essentially informal agreements that are
often enforced through
religious belief structures and so what
that says
is these things evolve which means
there's no bar to them evolving in some
creature in which the same bases for
such an agreement exists
so nothing nothing we know of as
religion exists outside of humans but
superstition
certainly does and so something that
some superstition that evolved that was
that was adhered to by everyone could
look this way what you really need is a
pen
uh penalty mechanism because the problem
is
that a free rider that recognizes the
opportunity created by everybody else
adhering to a superstition
is at advantage which is why the game
theory works the way it does and so what
you need is a mechanism
in which collective
policing serves this function but that's
not
out of the question in something like uh
chimps
dolphins elephants elephants maybe lions
wolves that kind of thing so um anyway
yes
it may occur to us later or somebody may
message us with an example but uh it's
certainly
not there's nothing about the
evolutionary dynamics that prevent it
it's just that most creatures won't have
the important feature that lets it work
which is
the mechanism to penalize a stranger
to penalize a stranger without a cost
that would be prohibitive
right okay first question
from last hours live stream girls i meet
are divided into those who have
intellectual interests
like sensitive men but are very woke
and the less woke who are not very
intellectual who seem to be consumerists
and prefer traditional gender roles
as a young man how can i date today well
that's a really
bleak binary picture that you have
painted
and i don't envy anyone being young and
entering the dating market right now
um i guess i'm
i'm a little devastated about that
description uh i know there are people
who young women who are both
intellectual and not woke
but i don't know where they hang out
particularly used to hang out in our
classrooms
but those don't exist anymore yeah but i
think the thing is
we even know that many of the young
women who were in our
classrooms uh you know continue into the
world some of them
remain single and some of them are not
but i think the thing is they suggest
a fact which is many many people are
finding something
very troubling in the mating and dating
market
and my recommendation would be
you figure out the mechanism you're
using to figure out who to date
is directing you to people who fall into
one of two categories that you don't
resonate with um the key i've had to
figure out how to define
and maybe create
that that third fourth fifth whatever it
is category uh that will have people in
it who you're
more interested in yes where would those
people tend i mean you know if they are
decrying the lack of
men who uh yeah fit with their model
we certainly i mean this is now a couple
of years old but we certainly would hear
from
students of both sexes straight students
from of both sexes
um that they were having a very hard
time finding people uh with whom they
were interested in having a relationship
yep and i you know for the most part
this wasn't about their standards being
ridiculous
right no i think in large measure it has
to do
with um almost everybody below a certain
age having been
sold a false bill of goods about
what is valuable and that in some sense
you're looking for the people who know
that the description of what they're
supposed to be pursuing
is hollow and you know largely driven by
um people who want to sell you something
rather than people who are actually
looking out for your interest
so my recommendation would be figure out
how to escape that you're looking for
oddballs
um you that could be a very rewarding
uh relationship or search for a
relationship and when you find
the right person where do you find the
oddballs like what it depends on what
kind of oddballs you want
you know one of my first guesses would
be um
look for people who are doing something
physical you know backpacking clubs or
bicycling or
you know sports teams you know summer
leagues pick up
pickup games of something that are co-ed
ultimate frisbee being particularly
um responsive to co-ed sport
um just because as i've said many many
times
and you have said as well uh engaging
with the world physically
makes it really so much harder to accept
a lot of the
the work of garbage that uh requires
that you
sort of have no feedback from the world
and you know physical engagement with
the world gives you that feedback and so
you get to you hone
your insight and i i think i mean this
is now hypothesis but
given that i've seen so few people who
are you know rock climbers or
carpenters or you know otherwise
engaging the world in a real way
who are also really buying into the work
stuff i think that it basically hones
your brain such that it's harder for you
to accept that totally
socially created conclusions that
intersectional
[ __ ] provides i'm having the thought
of a um a shirt
for the postmodern rock climbing club
in which the shirt depicts a
cliff rising above the cliff is the
sound of somebody falling ah
because that's what would happen in
post-modern rock climbing yeah um i mean
it could just even be post-modern rock
climbing club and could have the coyote
suspended above cliff not recognizing
uh gravity yet yes oh that too
there you go that's that's the point
that uh the idea that it doesn't
the rules of physics don't apply to you
until you recognize that they're there
uh is super amusing when it's a cartoon
coyote but not so amusing when you're
actually contending with these people uh
for
over issues of you know whether or not
to defund the police
i thought that cartoon was about market
failure as depicted through the acme
corporation
i think they were doing pretty well for
themselves weren't they i guess they
were yeah
yeah all right um well i would actually
suggest though this is just a proof of
concept but
um you say that you are encountering
uh girls i would suggest you start
searching for women uh and you are
finding women
who have intellectual interests they
like sensitive men
that's a little suspect um
and they're very woke well here's the
thing where would you find
intellectual women who have no patience
for woke
i would say the rationalist community
would be one place you would find such
people now those people are certainly
quirky but they tend to be quirky in a
kind of delightful way so
if that's the dynamic you're trying to
break
seek out a community where that
formulation doesn't make sense
okay i mean right i it seems to me that
maybe it's not all that numerous
well and my guess would also be that the
sex ratio is rather skewed in the
direction that this person writing in
would not prefer
but that's those are those are the
stereotypes i hold in my head that's
true but it's also
like it's a community nested within some
other communities
right and so anyway all i'm saying it's
really it was just a proof of concept
which is there's a place
in which that formulation wouldn't add
up yep so
it's also there will be others and and
you know i'm not suggesting you
take up with the rationalist community
cynically it's also an interesting
community i think
there are some ways in which there are
some things that i don't think
they get as well as they might but um
you know
we all don't get something as well as we
might and it would be an interesting
place to
to spend time yep
please expand on religion as extended
phenotype if it is an innate human
behavior how do i meet that need without
feeling like a hypocrite
or causing cognitive dissonance can we
use open label placebo
we know it's not real but it still works
so open label placebo is his uh i
presume his
uh request for a label for such a thing
yeah open label placebo um
so which is you know which is literally
false metaphorically true that's
that's the the same category yeah i mean
look
how do you meet the need this is in some
sense going to be
a personal question and i think
it depends a lot on who you are and what
need
you're meeting some of us do not find
that the absence
of a
metaphysical ultimate level
explanation robs life of meaning others
do find it kind of
frightening so really depends on what
thing you know
you it's it's like a little bit like
buying a house
you need to figure out what it is that
you absolutely require
and which things that others require are
places that you can borrow from to get
what you want
and um
i don't know i mean you know i i figure
out what your values actually are
yeah and what you know so i guess the
the thing maybe that you're
struggling with slightly pushing back
against in this question is the idea of
an innate human behavior right so
i think we see that religion or
religious-like tendencies are universal
across all human cultures um where it
has been
sought by anthropologists seeking such
things
so the universality of an evolved
cultural thing does not
inherently mean innate and you know you
won't find us
actually choosing usually to use the
word innate because it
it does raise these questions of well
then you know
do you even have a choice and more to
the point it raises the question for
something as complex as religion
which is what's what's it for what you
know what is the purpose of it
what is it that all these religious and
religious like beliefs are actually
doing for people and you know you
pointed out one of them
in your answer um you know i believe in
a metaphysical being that
um created and or is looking out for all
of us
um but of course we know that it you
know they also bring together community
it acts as a kind of social safety net
um so you know part of the reason that
you know we are likely seeing a growth
in the governmental social safety net in
the mid-20th century is as
religion declines as one that people can
rely on
and you know do we want do we all
want to have a social safety net of some
sort in place
i think i think the vast majority of us
do um but
should that be um in you know within a
religious community that might
also might also make demands of you
that you would not otherwise want
demanded of you so you know what are all
of the
needs that uh religion may meet
and figure out which of those things are
your top five values and priorities and
and then figure out from there what you
want to do
yep what are your thoughts on the
origins of
life small questions today by the way
thank you very much for your podcast i'm
thrilled by an opportunity to ask
questions of world-class scientists are
all professors in the u.s like you
yes all of them uh you are the brushes i
wish i would have had
thank you for that that's very nice so
the the first question was what are your
thoughts in the origins of life
yes uh well i'm for it yep and i think
it happened
i hate to be late to the party but uh
you know i'm here
you're here um i'm a drinker
i do actually um
yeah it's a tough question look we could
ask this with some regularity
i think people are fascinated for
understandable reasons
in uh you know origin of life questions
in some sense
it's one it's outside the realm
of what we actually study it's like
you know if you find a cosmologist and
you ask them
well what's outside the universe it's
like well you just
hit the border of where my expertise is
relevant
and so here's the thing i'm not worried
about whether there's a good
uh origin of life explanation i'm
actually quite convinced that
life straightforwardly arises
from certain dynamics it was very
interesting
and therefore will have done so many
many many times across the universe
yeah i find it almost inconceivable that
it would be uh
rare given
conditions that are conducive on on
planets that are within certain
constraints et cetera
right but um or large asteroids
the details yeah large afterwards not so
much probably
it's i think it's possible yeah not not
on but not in our solar system
um but anyway i'm not sure quite what to
say about it
i thought um you know
back in 1976 dawkins proof of concept
that there
you could lay out a a narrative
of essentially
non-living chemistry being selected by
wind blowing things across a dry
landscape and something sticking and
something is not sticking
um that was in the selfish gene yeah and
you know he didn't present it as this is
the answer
yes here's the story here's a possible
story you know and i'm not sure it was
his to begin with but i think the basic
point is
life is the extension
of a deeper pattern of selection
that it is selection plus heredity that
gives you
adaptation which eventually gives rise
to things that you would automatically
recognize as living
but selection happens
in the inorganic world all the time and
it results in
all of the patterns you are capable of
detecting that are outside of biology
so that same process
happens onto a pathway that leads to
something we call life
um at some point but it's not i don't
think it's in any way surprising that it
does that with some regularity so
um i guess the thing that i'm getting at
is people i think mistake the difficulty
for isolating what the exact pathway was
for the difficulty in establishing that
there is a pathway by which it would
happen and i think one of these is a
very low bar and one of them is a very
high bar
but the fact that it's hard to know what
happened here because the evidence is
gone
is not in and of itself daunting
teaching an environment after x number
of years doesn't produce mozart or bach
studies link brain differences and gifts
in sport and science
jordan peterson talks about iq and life
success why does nobody talk about
inequality with regard to talents
and iq is it because of political
correctness and social justice
thinking um couldn't we help find early
talents
and so reform education um
i think there's a hidden assumption here
that i think is just
dead wrong iq is real
but people tend to assume that iq is
genetically encoded which i think
there's much less evidence for than
people think
because what they find is that it is
hereditary but hereditary can mean
all kinds of things that have everything
to do with external
influences rather than a blueprint
for how to do cognition that exists in
the genome which it can't
so anyway i think
people assume too much from the fact of
they hear the word iq they assume that
that's a parameter that you are given
like
you know your structure for hemoglobin
and
they proceed from there and in fact iq
is
much more plastic than people imagine
and that we will eventually figure that
out and it does mean
that the chances that we are similarly
cognitively capable between populations
are much higher i would rate them as
much higher than other people
uh would tend to but in the end i'm i'm
just betting that's where it'll end up
all right there's a ton more to say
there but maybe in the interest of
getting through more questions we'll
stop there
consider the idea that much if not all
motive power of current social
disharmony is a symptom of the four new
kinds of radiation
coming to us around the sun since 1993
ubc among them
and increasing in magnitude affecting
humanity's evolution
i don't know anything about this
i don't know if this is true 93 yeah i
don't this this i've never heard this it
strikes me off
down my head is as something i i
wouldn't believe if you said it to me
um but uh four new kinds of radiation
coming to us around the sun since 1993
yeah something of any reason 1993 should
be special
nope um but if uh if the person who
wrote this
has a reference um that you would send
to
is it dark horse moderator zach is it
darkhorse moderator gmail.com
where the moderator is is 1993 going to
be
ozone hull
uh maybe it's around around then yeah
don't know my guess would be
um
[Music]
very unlikely yeah to be an abiotic
influence like that um i mean you know
the only way would be complete
disruption
of cognition significant enough to
derange
right although you know it's it's not
unprecedented right you know we you've
spoken before
about um the lead being taken out of
gasoline
and we see rates of violent crime
decreasing
um you know rates of violent crime in
1970s in cities
uh was quite high and lead was taken out
of gas in
late 70s something i can't remember
exactly when
but somehow it it tracks really nicely
like it it does seem to be
um you know in that again saying that
does not suggest that lead was the cause
of all violent crime
um but that seemed um led in the air uh
seemed to both decrease general iq in
people who lived
in uh very air polluted areas and also
increase
uh rates of um violence criminality so
you know it's not that there couldn't be
some abiotic factor that is contributing
to something
but it seems too too global too global
and i mean we also just don't know you
know maybe it's you know hole in the
ozone layer is what's being alluded to
here yeah
which would then be semi we'd expect the
penguins to be going crazy first
well they are because look at how they
dress um all the time
all the time yeah um but so yes
um you're right that global
use of tetraethyl lead would cause
um does seem to have caused some level
of social disruption or at least
plausibly dead
um what i'm doubting is four new kinds
of radiation
this yeah and i mean this may just be
imprecisely written you know
for four things that weren't reaching
the earth
before i don't know i mean but certainly
given
the little thing that i got into
thinking about ubc in the last couple of
weeks
yep ubc is hitting the earth at higher
rates now since uh
since the ozone hall has been has been
growing so that's you know that's at
least a possible connection here
next question keep up the good work you
once mentioned that market
markets are not a good tool for science
would you consider saying that
government is not a good
tool either for science for some issues
or wait no the government is not a good
tool for science or the
government not a good tool for science
either yeah
um oh government is a terrible tool for
some things i would argue that science
is not one of them because what science
really needs is
insulation from markets which means that
somebody needs to fund
that which we need done and to be done
insensitively to what the market
thinks of the conclusion yeah so what we
had you know so the government is an
answer that solves the problem of it
being done by rich aristocrats
right science being only available to
people who are sort of landed gentry
good government good governance is
a manifestation of the public
well-being so in order to get the
science done that is in our
collective interest governance
good governance is able to direct the
resources and immunize
the process from um
from market forces so i would say and it
allows a wider swath of humanity access
to becoming scientists yep
so i think this is one of these cases
where we've seen
malignant government and so people are
distrustful of it rightly
but that isn't an indictment of
governance it's an indictment of the
corrupt government
structures that we currently have yep
how would you respond to people whose
response to an unpopular scientific fact
is that most scientific studies are
corrupted by the institutions that are
funding them
are there any means for regular that is
non-scientist people to find out the
reliability of any study
this is an important question and it's
at some level going to require that you
learn
some of the both some of the
sort of code words that people use in
the papers
uh within the fields that you're
interested in discerning
and um become at least capable you know
somewhat scientifically literate
yourself that said
the peer-reviewed literature the primary
literature is mostly such a mess
that i really don't want to recommend
that to anyone unless you are required
to do it so
you know how do we how do we encourage
people to become more scientifically
literate
and to actually assess themselves what a
study says given that you know as we
have as we have
shown time after time right here
and we used to all the time in our
classrooms uh
not only are is most primary literature
um flawed to some degree and written so
as not to be decipherable by many people
outside of the field
but the media when when individual
research is covered by the media it's
almost always done so
so badly that if you just take the media
cover of a story you will end up with
some
wrong assessment of what the research
said so that's a description of the
problem without
solution making at all do you have any
suggestions i think it's i think it's
hopeless i think yeah no i mean
are you going to as a private citizen be
able to unpack
the garbage work in some field you
haven't
studied you shouldn't expect that you
will be able to
you unless you uh have
an extraordinary capacity and
interest in that field you're not going
to be able to train yourself to do it
without spending a huge amount of time
the best thing you can do
is find somebody with a track record of
figuring out where the work
is valid and where it isn't valid so in
some sense you know a
a naseem tele like figure can be your
guide
to what high quality work looks like and
what nonsense looks like
so you can sort of proxy and of course
nassim has his blind spots
but his problem he's following him is
probably
better than it is trying to you know
reinvent the wheel
yeah in terms of
you know i don't want to say it's
hopeless i mean because this is
something that
um i in particular used to try to help
students with is try to figure out
demonstrate how to become intelligent
consumers unfortunately of the
scientific literature
and you know with the recognition going
in that it's not written
um to be understood by outsiders and yes
scientists view everyone who's not
actively doing science in that field for
the most part as outsiders
um so it's you know it's not it's not an
uncorrupt uh
phenomenon at all so
one one thing and this is by no means
perfect
uh is to look for the hypothesis you
know if you are actually looking
at a paper that was written here a piece
of primary literature meaning paper
a paper written by the people who
actually did the research itself
look for the hypothesis clearly stated
up front in both the abstract and the
introduction
and increasingly scientists who are not
hypothesis driven will game this and
pretend that they had hypothesis all
along and put it up front
but it's also amazing how many papers
don't even pretend
and so if you're looking at research
that doesn't even pretend that it had a
hypothesis
uh then i would say right away you can
say i you know i just i don't really
need to spend time here
um and when i you know when we were
professors and i was
asked to do peer review of papers uh for
a variety of journals
it was amazing to me how many papers
my primary review that went back was
i see no evidence of a hypothesis here i
can't recommend that you publish this
i was not particularly beloved among
journal editors as a result because
the number of papers coming in that just
had no pretense hypothesis was
amazing yeah no it is a total failure
but even in the case of the ones that
that have it i think you're dealing with
a situation
and i've forgotten what the name of this
principle is but um
you are often where you are an expert
able to detect just how bad reporting is
just journalistic reporting on something
where you know a lot
and then the reporting and every other
thing looks okay um
now increasingly that's not true but 10
years ago that was
a widely reported
pattern what that means is that the
reporting sucks in all of those places
you're just capable of detecting it in
the one where you have the expertise
and my point would be
science it's like that right
you will find in each place there's the
stuff that's not being said
you know i mean you can look at the
the sars cove to stuff
uh from the beginning about the natural
origin of this thing
right you had to have a certain kind of
expertise to be able to spot how
nonsense
filled this story was but if you did
have it it was clear and yet you've got
and if you didn't have it you were told
you were cracked by conspiracy
hypothesis right for believing it's such
a thing
exactly and so you know to this day
we're dealing with that outgrowth which
is
uh to see the emptiness of that
explanation
of the natural origin explanation is to
sideline yourself um but i wouldn't
expect
it's not it's not on you the fact is the
fields are broken they're broken because
of perverse incentives
it's rare to find a field where that's
really not true
and but i mean i i i applaud the
question so i feel like you're giving
the person writing and
out but i don't think i'm going to guess
here given the name
that she uh wants an out she's looking
for
a road forward right like some what what
can i do as someone who is not
uh a scientist to interpret
scientific findings um and not just have
to
sit down and shut up when people say ah
you can't trust that because
institutions corrupt science it is both
true that institutions corrupt science
and that good science is done
well yes on the other hand it's a little
you know if the person said
um i'm not comfortable with the fact
that
the products i buy uh result in
the misery of the people involved in
producing them or the people downstream
from the pollutants and making them
how can i um you know
build my life around products that don't
hurt people and the answer is
you can't it's not on you if this is
something we have to collectively solve
because the individual level solution
doesn't exist
um so you know i don't like saying that
but i also don't want to lead you to
believe that there's a good solution to
i think it's a little bit different
though okay um because with regard to
products
and um taking it on yourself you know
minimize your impact you are
you are experiencing the personal
responsibility vortex the coin that you
termed in your ted talk years ago term
that i coined
did i say coin that you termed yeah well
i don't think you did that i didn't no i
wouldn't have
no no you would not have so the person
i can't get it right the personal
responsibility vortex
a term that you coined in a ted talk
years ago well done
uh is is would be the thing that you're
talking about with regard to
uh seeking to minimize as much as
possible the impact of your
consumption choices on the environment
for instance which
um if there are other reasons for you to
do so terrific but
if you suffer all the costs of
minimizing the costs other people win
at um at cost to you whereas in this
case this person is trying to better
themselves
and not simply make the collective
better oh
i get why this person wants to do this
and i
want them to do this but i also know
that you're
wading into fields in which you've got
reciprocity networks in which people are
you know
passing each other's papers through peer
review because they want their papers
passed through peer review
i mean look here's the thing the
year before the replication crisis broke
in psychology
it was completely obvious that there
would be one and it's not
psychology psychology is where it broke
first any place that you've got
statistics and p-values it was obvious
that there was a perverse incentive that
was going to result
in the complete derangement of all of
the work downstream of this
because the way you advanced your career
was to publish papers the way you
publish papers was to get significance
the way you got significance
was to you know massage your day green
jelly beans cause cancer
they sure do yeah right they sure do
jelly beans cause cancer so the point is
look
it was obvious there was a replication
crisis in light of a replication crisis
how do you figure out which results in
psychology are right
turns out pretty close to none of them
right so what do you do about that
there's just nothing to do you know and
you know the thing to do
i mean it is the personal responsibility
vortex the thing to do is to demand
science that actually works and the way
you do that is you
provide an incentive structure that
doesn't cause people to publish bad work
in order to advance their careers
now we do need a drink
given so this is very much like a
question that we started with
um so we may just uh refer back to that
answer
given one human society's need for
religion and
two the waning of religion in the west
might the rise of the number of people
who are willing to adopt or invent
bsc ideologies be tied to their now
desperate innate need to believe in
something
i don't know what bsc is here i feel
like i'm just forgetting an obvious
acronym
um but so this this
this differs a little bit from the
earlier question or questions about
religion
uh and then it asks whether or not uh we
we feel a need to believe in something
that that belief
may be a sort of a human universal
desire
and that in a in a world that is
becoming
uh less coherent simultaneously more
global so that we can see
apparently uh what everyone else is
doing even though we know that it's
highly curated if not worse
and we can well maybe maybe that
maybe that so i would i think there's
something very much to this idea
that we have a need to believe but i
don't think it works the way people
think it does
um so it drives people crazy especially
uh died in the wool of science types
when i say you can't do science without
a certain amount of faith drives them
crazy yes it does
but it's absolutely true it's me too a
little bit it's provable
well but here's the thing it's not much
of a claim right
the fact is you do not know that this is
not
all a hallucination and in fact there
are explanations that could make it one
right if this was a simulation maybe
it's a simulation to see
what a mind-like collection of circuits
does with certain kinds of information
you can't prove that that's not where
you are so you have to have faith but we
can't get very far if we spend time on
on such a hypothesis right worthless so
the point is what do you do
you you've got two choices okay we're
i'm going to dichotomize i'm going to go
i'm going to go ibra max candy on this
right oh boy
but this is a real dichotomy you have
two choices you can spend
your entire life on one question
on which you are guaranteed to make no
progress
right or you can decide that's not
happening
i'm going to take on faith that this is
not a simulation designed to figure out
what my collection of circuits will do
with information that looks like this in
fact i'm real
tables are real i have mechanisms to
figure out who they are if i go into the
laboratory i can run an experiment and
it involves
actual equipment spitting out actual
data that i can then evaluate for better
or worse
right i can assume that i have the
ability to detect the actual world and
that that allows me to do science and
discover things
and my feeling is tell you what what's
the cost that's good what's the cost
if i just accept i can't rule out that
this is a simulation designed to see
what i will do
but assuming it's not i can do all this
other stuff i'm just gonna take it on
faith that the
universe is real and uh if it ain't
the cost is zero okay so we need to
believe something in order to make
progress in whatever realm it is we're
trying to make progress
in right but the thing is that thing
once you do that once you accept that
first little bit of faith then you're
going to find it
so much well and i mean that one's the
ultimate bargain
i'm guaranteed to waste everything for
nothing or i get
access to everything based on a kind of
faith i'm not going to worry too much
about it so you're going to give
abram candy credit for this no i'm just
going to go dichotomous because it's
actually dichotomous in this case
but but the point is okay you accept
that
and it's such a you know it's such a
rush to actually believe that the
universe is real and that you can
interact with it right
it's just such a great reward that then
you say well
maybe there's some other bargains not
quite as good as that one i get
everything for nothing
but i get a lot for a little right all
the heuristics that make your visual
system
work you are taking on faith that things
end where
they seem to end right and generally
they do
and then occasionally they don't you
know what happens when they don't
you plummet to your death no well
sometimes sometimes but try not to do
that so okay
i'm working on it you can get this all
from like a couple of subreddits right
that you've got the subreddits that
focus on
you know optical illusions and it's not
always optical but optical is a very
compelling one
right where your heuristics mislead you
and you see something that isn't
right right and then there's the
subreddit what could go wrong
one of your favorites i know well you
can learn all sorts of things
sometimes late at night before you go to
bed you're scrolling through
that like dude how do you sleep do you
know how many dreams look like i will
never know how many deaths i have
avoided because i'm a devotee of what
could go wrong and i learn about these
things on my phone rather than by making
the error so anyway the point is
heuristics are like an algorithmic kind
of faith
right they trade on the fact that your
system for
using photons bouncing around a room to
assess where objects are and how you can
interact with them
actually work and in general it's such a
good deal you don't even think you're
making a deal
and then every so often you get one
wrong and it becomes oh yeah it was a
heuristic and every so often you know
one and one in a thousand times the
heuristic fails
so anyway my point is yes we need to
believe things because we're structured
to use heuristics because it's such a
damn bargain
and then sometimes you pay the cost but
um the question is how much does this
have to do with our need to believe in
something like
a being above who gives a damn about us
and all of that
yep and i think it differs a lot for
different people i don't need there to
be a god above
yeah some people do but i think it is a
mistake to assume
that our need to believe in something is
synonymous with our need to believe in
purpose in the universe because some
people have that need and some people
don't
yeah uh 50 minutes oh boy uh let me just
say
uh to defend you against uh the idea
that you're spending your last waking
minutes
looking at what could go wrong and i
can't imagine how you sleep i tend to
spend my last waking minutes reading
about well
if the last week is any uh indicator
either north korea or 20th century china
which also does not exactly make for
wonderful dreams so
i suppose to each their own uh with
regard to how to plague their own dream
space
in fact in both those cases the only
reason that china and north korea are
not on what could go wrong because it's
hard to know how to photograph the whole
thing yeah yeah yeah oh man there's so
many good questions that we're not going
to get to
most of them let me do um
one more here and then
then we'll go to the superchat from this
hour
should unity promote platonic dialogues
annually for the public to read and
incorporate into presidential speeches
this can recover lost fundamentals and
deploy the best of idw
long-form resources for instance mcraven
something on true courage latches is
that a name or a
i don't know what that means i don't
know what the latches means
but anyway
look to be honest with you i think unity
2020
is a manifestation it is
a version of something of which there
are many versions in many different
realms and frankly they have to get
together right i think unity 2020
has a lot to do with blockchain
and i think it has a lot to do with open
source and i think it has a lot to do
with game b
and idw and that all of these things are
proof of concept prototypes that have
solved
some canonical problem in some zone
and the point is we need to stop
recognizing them as separate projects we
need to recognize that really
it is the overarching project we are
about which is
how do we take all of the various
failure modes learn from them
and build around them for the next phase
of humanity
because if we don't there ain't going to
be a next phase of humanity
so yes to your point but maybe we can
expand it a bit
uh so we're switching to the next uh
super chat but i want to make i want to
read one more comment from this one and
then we will come back to some of these
questions in
episode 40. suggestion turn defund
into refund at the police refund doesn't
make sense in terms of normal policing
and lends itself to better unpacking and
conversation so i read that because i
actually had exactly this thought
earlier today and thought
um you know how it rhymes it's such a
match
otherwise and uh you know i think i
think what we really want is and
is more funding than we had before in
order to
start fixing the problems and then
potentially scale back but
it's at least potentially an interesting
linguistic starting point
yes um two problems one
the word refund and refund are two
different things
um but you know maybe maybe you can get
around that
um because you know in a defund the
police world refund seems to be the
opposite
but the other thing is i really want you
know i don't want to be caricatured as
somebody
who thinks we need huge police budgets
yeah i just think that the police
budgets are large
because the police are being used to
solve a set of problems that are not
best solved by the police which is not
so far
from a credible version of the claims
that are being made but
the point is that argues for doing it
right
you know to the extent that the police
are dealing with
a mental health crisis because we have
no solution for people
who have crippling mental health issues
and therefore end up
on the streets involved in petty and
worse crime
that's not an elegant solution to this
problem at all
the police don't belong in that equation
except very rarely and so
figuring out how not to use the police
as a cheap solution
to problems is the key so
at some level i want enough i want
people to be imaginative enough that
what we're really saying is
render the police less necessary
right let's get them out of the jobs
they shouldn't be doing and let's have
them do the jobs they need to be doing
and you know there's a lot a lot a lot
is possible but not if
your point is let's go after the police
and let's be personal about it
on a scale from unicycle to 18 wheeler
how tired are you of the kleptocraptic
duopoly
did it say kleptocraptic uh no it
doesn't i made that up
leptocratic on a scale from unicycle to
18 wheeler how tired are you of the
kleptocratic
duopoly um i like kleptocraptic i would
say
i am panamax boat tired of the
kleptocraptic
duopoly they have no wheels at all
we're simply measuring wheels i thought
it was like getting unrecycled 18 wheel
that looks like a wheel continuum to me
it does but it was also a size continuum
and so uh you know panamax boat panama
i'll tell you what if it's about wheels
some of the panamax boats these are
boats that are the maximum dimensions to
fit in the locks of the panama canal
they're very big and some of them if i
understand it correctly actually have
basically factories in them that finish
automobiles
in transit to basically smooth out the
supply chain so that you're not wasting
time you know the cars are sitting idle
on their way they could also be being
finished on their way
so anyway a panamax boat full of cars
that are in the process of being
finished
has six wheels per average
car that's a lot of wheels six
i think all you got four
plus a spare plus a steering i know you
were going there
[Laughter]
wow okay i feel good about it i know you
do
uh this is a logistics question
installed zoom tried to click into
saturday's meetings with no success in
the future how can we be certain to get
access to meetings to contribute
apologies if this was already answered
just getting home so this is going to be
about the
campfire i don't know if you want to
just take that to campfire let's just
explain people
this is campfire i think so that's the
there was a saturday
meeting right well i don't know if
they're talking about um
i don't think it's campfire i think this
is uh this is about
patreon discussions and i'm dismayed to
find out that anybody is having trouble
clicking into the meeting
um there is access to me is to
contribute
um okay well there's i mean there's
so you only do you do this he does it
once a month the first saturday and
sunday
of the month and then we do our private
q a on
the last sunday of the month um so it
may be that you um
i i don't know so maybe if it is about
patreon
uh send a message into that patreon i
don't know if you'll see it
send a message to uh darkhorsemoderator
gmail.com with more specificity around
this what this was
yeah we will take care of it but be as
specific as possible about what happened
um it is possible that you missed a
password
associated with getting into the meeting
we'll get it figured yep
have you heard of ralston college it's
founded on enlightenment values of many
great intellectuals like jordan peterson
involved
it may be the last place offering a real
humanities education we were actually
one of the many things that we weren't
able to do because of lockdown was
go to i think it was to be their first
big weekend-long event
uh that was supposed to be maybe in
savannah um this last spring
uh as i understand it it's not actually
operational yet and i doubt it will
become operational
in the near future given that so many
colleges are failing to figure out how
to operate
but yeah jordan peterson is on the
board or the founding people
there are a lot of good people
associated with it
but i do not think that it is yet
happening but yeah for people who don't
know about it ralston college
r-a-l-s-t-o-n which i think is actually
2b
happening in savannah georgia um they
have a website and you can learn a
little bit about it
in game of thrones the unsullied are in
army and bunix
would eunuchs make acceptable soldiers
in the real world or is it functional
fictional nonsense or awoke pun what
would such an army's strengths and
weaknesses be
thanks from echo well
geez i don't know i mean the thing about
the unsullied
in game of thrones is that we don't know
by what mechanism they were trained
and so we actually don't know what
incentives drive them we know what
incentives have been
removed from them but game of thrones
explores
this trope in multiple places where it
basically i mean theon greyjoy
gets remanufactured as a
mental slave of i can't remember
ramsay yeah but anyway the idea that you
could rebuild somebody
by altering and and varus ah
i wanted to bring up varys because but
okay so but before you speak so you're
you're focusing entirely on incentives
and whether or not it would sort of work
coherently as an army behaviorally
um i suspect given some of echo's
previous questions that she is at least
as interested in the question
of anatomy and physiology and so it
really depends
on at what point this would-be army
had these unfortunate surgeries done to
them that
little boys uh who are castrated are not
going to become
uh warriors who are able who are going
to be able to
uh actually win against actually intact
male armies
right uh if they were castrated after
they'd gone through male puberty
um they would have uh you know male
anatomy
and male you know male physiology and
physique and and body mass and all of
that and yes it would change somewhat
at the point that they were no longer
producing much testosterone on their own
um but they would they would be built
like men whereas
uh you castrate a little boy and he's
not gonna end up being built like a man
and so it wouldn't be an effective army
right and so in some sense this goes
back to
your distinction between uh
organizational and activational effects
which i think is if you wanted to invest
somewhere in a piece of knowledge that
would liberate you from all sorts of
scientific nonsense this would be a
great place to do it
um but then you also have the
technological question which is
okay if you get the advantage of the
organizational effects
that make a masculinized army and then
you get presumably the control that you
this question is predicated on a um
someone who wants to control an army
they're wondering if such an army would
work so that's what we're talking about
um the organizational effects create the
masculinized body which is better for
fighting the
lack of the androgens
being produced increases control but
then
technologically speaking you can
introduce and remove androgens at will
which allows even greater control so if
you imagine
the unsuspecting in modern times right
exactly
so the last thing i was going to say on
this topic is that um
uh martin no the author
uh oh george george r martin tells us
something about what
he actually thinks about this castration
stuff because he says
as people are talking about varus in
early seasons
that nobody trusts a eunuch which is
ironic because in some sense the eunuch
should be more trustworthy by virtue of
the fact
that they're not being jerked around by
their gonads but
martin's point if it fits martin's point
and i assume it is
is that the lack
of this distortion of maleness it makes
the person less reliable because you
don't know actually what they're after
no clues to motive right men can be
relied upon to be after certain things
and a man who is not after those things
is a mystery and therefore dangerous um
so
anyway i don't know an unsolid army
could you know if
if they had masculinized bodies
sufficiently enough to be
adequate warriors could actually be
more confusing and surprising and
therefore more powerful against
intact male armies yes although in the
case of the unsullied they are so well
trained that even
liberated they are not the least bit
liberated right
so anyway i i think martin does a pretty
good job of exploring this
in game of thrones that you know you
have the full range from a completely
free agent
freed by the lack of gonads to
completely subservient
agents by virtue of the training regimen
that accompanied castration yep
hi bretton heather thanks for all you do
my wife and i are expecting our first
child in january
congratulations as successful parents do
you have any recommended readings or
general advice for raising successful
children
thanks uh we have uh
we have a list of things that we put
into the book that we're writing
in the chapter on parenthood and
relationship
um and in part because
there really isn't that out there you
know evolutionary parenting
isn't yet a field there are some you
know halfway decent
things that i feel like i read
occasionally but mostly
it was us figuring things out as we went
alone
from an evolutionary perspective
watching as these amazing little
critters
quickly started trying to game their
situation
and us and we responded
with with love and putting a stop to
their gaming
um so i i'm gonna try just general
framework
general framework is kids are designed
to be parented they are designed to be
raised
the purpose of childhood is to make
highly
functional adults the purpose of life is
not
to be satisfied it is to be
functional and all of this
amounts to a system that works pretty
well
by intuition except for one fact which
is
you live in the modern world and the
modern world is not the one
for which children are designed and it
is not the one for which parents are
designed
and that means that you need to be hyper
vigilant
about the distortion that comes from
modernity
short of modernity this would be i would
not say an easy job because it's
very expensive in many regards
but it is a straightforward job in
normal circumstances and a very
confusing job
when for example your children will
face market forces that are attempting
to manipulate them into doing things
that are not
good for them because it's in somebody
else's financial interest
that's not something a hunter-gatherer
would encounter
so be very on your guard
about novel influences that potentially
disrupt the processing that your kid
does
but in general trust your intuition when
psychological experts tell you you must
be very careful not to love your kids
too much
they have to cry themselves to sleep or
they'll become dependent they are full
of [ __ ] and that's obvious
and just go with your gut on this one
right
um kids are designed to be parented
you're designed to have the
the right feeling if you're normal
you're designed to have the right
feelings towards them
to the extent that you uh want to
embrace them you probably do to the
extent they're driving you crazy
you probably need to tell them so it's
straightforward
but for modernity okay let's do a few
more
uh and then we'll stop for today in the
age of functional mostly 3d printed
semi-automatics will gun control remain
even possible for much longer
uh no yeah well that's already a matter
of
um limits the amount more to people's
limits of imagination than to any
practical detail
yeah what role do you believe that
xenoestrogens such as bpa phthalates and
analogs are playing in the rate of
transsexualism
given their established high occurrence
in human bodies and known effects on the
inah3 the human sdn i don't recognize
those last two
abbreviations but the the larger
question is
basically we've got um
estrogens entering the water supply
entering the environment at rates that
are
far higher than they ever have before
from things like phytoestrogens which is
to say that estrogens
and their analogues exist in nature
but we have been synthesizing them and
then
releasing them through our trash and our
urine
into water supply that then effectively
feminizes boys
uh and uh absolutely that's happening
yes um you know it's it's you know how
explanatory is it
how many how many hypotheses are there
each of which have some role
to explain in the actual legitimately
increasing rates of transsexualism
i don't know um but it is certainly one
factor
yeah it's certainly one factor there's
also clearly
a cultural contagion factor
which dovetails with a general
general disruption of normal
environments so
sure but that's i mean i think there are
there are many
many things going on with regard to the
rise and trans and this person
specifically writes transsexualism
and i think that's intentional right
like transsexualism and transgender
you know you know as i as i asked in my
recent letter to
to abigail schreier in our letter wiki
about specifically
the contagion aspect of the rise in in
in teenage girls declaring themselves
transgender at what point did we stop
calling him
calling it transsexual and started
calling it transgender this is
a muddling of the issue at best and
frankly
um transgender you know acting
in ways that is are historically more
like the other sex would act um should
warrant certainly nothing hormonally or
surgically and probably nothing at all
um you know at least within some
confines whereas you know tran
transsexualism like actually
legitimately feeling like one of the
many
manifestations of your sex um is out of
whack with the
sex um that you that you are you know
usually it's your
it's your brain telling you for sure
that the sex that your chromosomes
and your gametes and your anatomy and
your physiology
say you are is not the thing that you
say you are you know is
are are xenoestrogens contributing to
basically a broader array of intersex
conditions effectively yeah
i think i think they are but you know
but there's also
social contagion which may have nothing
at all to do with that
but it's really a different evolution of
of
transness but what i wanted to get at
was the interaction between these things
i think that there's some gateway which
looks
like i feel like something's off
right i feel like something is off and i
want it not to be off anymore
and so i'm looking for the thing that's
off so i can
fix it right and the point is okay one
of the things this lab will be off
is that you are getting a lot of uh
um estrogens that you're not supposed to
be exposed to
if you're uh a boy or you're not
supposed to be exposed to them if you're
anybody but if you're a boy it has a
particular
effect which is making you feel even
more off and then somebody
says you know what a lot of people who
are feeling off are really just fine
they're just
facing a kind of oppression where
civilization is telling them that they
are something
it's denying who they really are and it
sounds like you know what
maybe that's it maybe i really am
something
else and i would feel fine if i was that
thing but i'm being told i'm this other
thing and that's why everything seems so
wrong and so people embrace it
and then the point is well that didn't
work because everything is still
crazy right you're still interfacing
with a world that
is not well suited to you and so no
wonder that this is largely happening
at the point that these kids are
teenagers when guess what you're doing
as a teenager as you're trying to figure
out who you are
and why you no longer are the kid you
once were and are not yet the adult that
you might become
or are hoping to become or haven't yet
even imagined what it might look like to
become
that that age that era in your life is
exactly about it doesn't
quite feel right this isn't fitting i'm
trying to figure out what it is that i'm
going to be doing
and so to have a political ideology move
in and say we've got the solution for
you it involves going into the knife and
taking hormones that are going to
change your life forever well that's
that's child abuse
yeah it is i mean at the same moment
that you frankly
have um cardi b
telling you what uh you know the cool
sexuality is which is
insane then you have joe biden sitting
down with cardi b
for an interview because the democratic
party is of course on board
you can't make this stuff up the point
is everything is broadcasting some
message that you can't possibly process
normally because it's not a normal
message it's a malevolent message
and anyway i think what you're finding
is a lot of people looking for
the same thing that makes them
susceptible to get rich quick schemes
and
uh snake oil right the i the sense that
there's got to be some way
there's just got to be some way tell me
what switch i can flip
and now hey guess what we've got the
ultimate switch if you find
something off-putting about the sexual
message you're being expected to
interface with
then there's a reason for that and it's
called trans and
here's what you got to do and so anyway
the point is
the bpa and the other estrogens that you
may be taking in
feed into the sense that something isn't
right and then this other thing
doesn't have to be connected to it
directly it just has to be connected to
the fact that people
for whom things don't feel right are
looking for an answer and this answer
happens to be fashionable at the moment
which isn't
to say that there aren't real
transgender people which there are and
there
always have been but the point is the
level of it
the degree to which this has risen as an
issue
can just be a matter of lots of things
that create a sense of being abilities
and a small number of solutions that are
becoming fashionable and
there you have it yeah okay two more
questions
what are we at sec okay we'll do two
more here
the next one is uh a comment um although
there is a rhetorical question at the
end
um if the goal is to move toward a
polychronic way of thinking can i
discuss my sex life at work since
personal and work are combined
can i have sex at work i don't think
it's well thought through
this person concludes yeah yeah it's not
um it's not yeah it
you make a good point i mean it's pretty
it's far better than they do
right yes um brett you often refer to
rent-seeking elites
can you offer one or two specific
examples to illustrate their behavior
and make them tangible to
me um so let's say
that you run a
fossil fuel extraction
company and you
become skeptical of anthropogenic global
climate change because it is politically
in your interest
to continue um selling your fossil fuels
as long as possible and even though it
might be in civilization's interest
to switch to a modality of moving from
place to place or working from home
or you know battery driven cars from
solar power whatever it is
so you become motivated to obstruct
the new mechanism because you're
profiting from the old mechanism
um so you are externalizing the harm of
fossil fuels
in an effort uh to maintain your profit
stream
um you have not you have contributed
something to the market you've
contributed fossil fuels which have a
value but they also have a cost
which because it's externalized rather
than internalized you don't experience
directly
and so anyway this deranges our
conversation about
atmospheric chemistry and you may fund
research that results in
there being more confusion on this issue
than there should have been so that's an
example of a rent-seeking elite
protecting their profit stream um
while uh deranging the conversation in a
way that externalizes harm
well done all right i think we're done
we're there yeah
all right cool so
uh as as always uh join us on our
patreons for
a variety of of perks including access
to a private
monthly q a uh at brett's at the higher
levels
uh he does a couple of two hour
conversations among a small group of
people um on saturday and sunday
the first saturday and sunday of the
month and there's a discord
uh that you have access to at either of
them the clips channel will have
some clips chosen by a guy that we trust
and like very much
um and he puts them up there and
this channel also this channel subscribe
if you don't subscribe
comment um and please come join unity if
you haven't done it yet there's going to
be opportunities for you to influence
our process
upcoming very soon so now would be a
great time to get on our mailing list
all right thanks everyone we will see
you next time
[Music]
you